Peter Coleman runs an outfit called the International Center for Cooperation and Conflict Resolution at Columbia University, which means that he spends a lot of time thinking about disputes between people that seem unresolvable and what can be done in those situations. And he tells this story-- he wrote about this in a book, too-- about the abortion debate in Boston back in the 1990s. Boston is a very Catholic city, of course.
彼得·科尔曼（Peter Coleman）在哥伦比亚大学运营着一个名为“国际合作与冲突解决中心”的机构，这意味着他花费大量时间思考人与人之间看似无法解决的争端，以及在这些情况下可以做些什么。他讲过这样一个故事——他在书里也写过——关于20世纪90年代波士顿的堕胎辩论。当然，波士顿是一个非常天主教化的城市。
You know, inflammatory rhetoric, really on both sides. And then in 1994, there was a shooting that took place. John Salvi III went into two clinics in Brookline, Massachusetts. And he shot and killed two women. And he took a rifle and put it to the head of one woman and shot and killed her, and said, that's what you get. You should pray the rosary more. I think the pro-life movement was ashamed and infuriated by what had happened. I think the pro-choice movement was terrified and traumatized. And so the governor, the archdiocese, called for dialogue.
你知道，双方都有煽动性的言论。然后，在1994年，发生了一起枪击事件。约翰·萨尔维三世（John Salvi III）进入了马萨诸塞州布鲁克莱恩的两家诊所。他开枪打死了两名妇女。他拿着步枪抵住其中一名妇女的头部，开枪打死了她，并说：“这就是你们的下场，你们应该多念玫瑰经。”我认为反堕胎运动对所发生的一切感到羞愧和愤怒。我认为支持堕胎选择的运动感到恐惧和创伤。因此，州长和大主教区呼吁进行对话。
Which is kind of a standard thing that people do after a tragedy like this. The idea is if we just talk to each other better, people wouldn't be getting killed. Let's have a dialogue. And in this case, the dialogue actually happened. Three leaders from the local pro-life movement agreed to meet with three leaders of the local pro-choice movement. And they agreed it all had to happen in secret because of just how sensitive the whole issue was, because how supporters on each side of the issue would see them meeting with people on the other side. They agreed to meet exactly four times.
这在这样的悲剧之后是人们通常会做的事情。人们的想法是，如果我们能更好地沟通，人们就不会被杀害了。让我们进行一场对话吧。在这种情况下，对话确实发生了。当地反堕胎运动的三位领导人同意与当地支持堕胎选择运动的三位领导人会面。他们同意这一切必须秘密进行，因为整个问题极其敏感，也因为双方的支持者会如何看待他们与对方阵营的人会面。他们同意总共会面四次。
So they brought these women together. And reportedly, the pro-life group had met in a Friendly's beforehand and prayed, because they really feared sitting down at the table with this other side. They really believed that just being near them could taint them, could affect them. Because in their mind at the time, they were murderers. And to be with them not only was dangerous, but also could affect their reputations within their own communities, and could put their life at risk, given what had just happened.
所以他们把这些女性聚集在一起。据报道，反堕胎小组事先在一个名为Friendly's的餐厅会面并进行了祈祷，因为她们真的很害怕与对方坐在同一张桌子上。她们真的相信仅仅与对方接近就可能玷污她们，可能会影响她们。因为在她们当时看来，对方是杀人犯。与她们待在一起不仅危险，而且考虑到刚刚发生的事情，还可能影响她们在各自社区内的声誉，并可能使她们的生命处于危险之中。
At first, the conversation was hard. Even though they agreed to some guidelines and how to have this conversation in a way that they felt would be constructive, it was hard to hold to those guidelines initially.
起初，谈话很困难。尽管她们同意了一些指导方针，并同意以一种她们认为具有建设性的方式进行这次谈话，但最初很难坚持这些方针。
And you write about that, that there was a lot of finger pointing back and forth. Everybody thought, we're not going to do any finger pointing. But in fact, they couldn't help themselves is what you write.
你对此有相关的写作，提到双方有很多指责。每个人都认为，我们不会互相指责。但事实上，正如你所写，她们无法克制自己。
It's what they did. It's what they had been doing. They were used to doing it. They knew the talking points. And it was so hard to try to put those away.
她们确实那么做了。那是她们一直以来的做法。她们习惯了这样做。她们熟悉那些谈话要点。要尝试放下这些东西是如此困难。
And because, basically, each side saw the other side as just--
而且因为，基本上，每一方都认为另一方仅仅是……
Evil. As evil or insane. Absolutely.
邪恶的。是邪恶的或者是疯子。绝对是这样。
These are precisely the conflicts that Peter Coleman studies. They're the conflicts where whatever the original dispute happened to be about, everybody has moved past that long ago. And things have snowballed. And people started to organize their identities around the conflict. Coleman says that these happen in families. They happen in universities. They happen in politics, of course. In looking at all the international disputes since 1816, there are researchers who've calculated that 5% of those disputes were these enduring conflicts. They lasted, on average, 36 years. They accounted for half of all wars between nations, 3/4 of all civil wars.
这些正是彼得·科尔曼研究的冲突。在这些冲突中，无论最初的争议是什么，每个人早就不再关注了。事情已经像滚雪球一样愈演愈烈。人们开始围绕冲突组织自己的身份认同。科尔曼说这些情况发生在家庭中。它们发生在大学里，当然也发生在政治中。在观察1816年以来的所有国际争端时，有研究人员计算出，其中5%是这些持久的冲突。它们平均持续了36年。它们占了所有国家间战争的一半，占所有内战的四分之三。
Of course, the question is, what do we do about these conflicts? How do we resolve them? Well, Peter Coleman says that two things can happen. First, sometimes a big disruptive event can come along and shake everything up. Like the Arab Spring could conceivably end up nudging the dynamic of the Palestinian-Israeli conflict. And he says, second, sometimes it's just long-term changes lead each side to be more open to getting along and less open to violence.
当然，问题在于，我们该如何应对这些冲突？我们如何解决它们？嗯，彼得·科尔曼说会发生两件事。首先，有时会发生重大的破坏性事件，从而彻底改变一切。比如，“阿拉伯之春”有可能最终推动巴以冲突的动态。他说，第二，有时只是长期的变化导致每一方都更愿意和睦相处，而减少暴力倾向。
In Boston in the 1990s, after these abortion clinic murders, these women, over the course of their four meetings--
在20世纪90年代的波士顿，在这些堕胎诊所谋杀案之后，这些女性，在她们四次会面的过程中——
They start to get some sense of the other person-- of the other group-- that's different from what they came in with. They start to experience each other as women who are decent women. And ultimately, they end up speaking in secret for six years, and really come to know each other and come to deeply respect and care for each other, one another, across the divide, all six of these women.
她们开始对另一个人——对另一个群体——有了某种不同于她们最初进来的理解。她们开始体验到彼此是体面的女性。最终，她们秘密谈话了六年，真正了解了对方，并开始在鸿沟之上深深尊重和关心彼此，这六位女性皆是如此。
A decade later, when we checked with these women this past week, the three of them that we reached-- on both sides of the issue-- told us that the experience of these talks was life-changing for them. On NPR's All Things Considered back in 2003, one of them, Frances Hogan, told reporter Margot Adler about how she had been changed.
十年后，当我们在过去一周核实这些女性的情况时，我们联系到的三位——来自这一问题的双方——告诉我们，这次谈话的经历改变了她们的生活。在2003年美国国家公共电台（NPR）的《全盘考虑》（All Things Considered）节目中，其中一位成员弗朗西斯·霍根（Frances Hogan）告诉记者玛戈·阿德勒（Margot Adler），她是如何被改变的。
I could share a little anecdote-- two little anecdotes-- when, the day of the Salvi shootings, I was on one of the local television news channels with Nicki Nichols Gamble They had wanted a per--
我可以分享一个小轶事——两个小轶事——在萨尔维枪击案发生的那天，我和尼基·尼科尔斯·甘布尔（Nicki Nichols Gamble）一起上了当地的一个电视新闻频道，他们想要一个……
We should say that's another one of the--
我们应该说那是另一个……
Another participant in the dialogue. And we had been called there to kind of-- I guess, as representatives of the pro-life and pro-choice positions. However, before the show began, Nicki and I wound up in the same waiting room to go on television. And she was there with her husband. And I came in and sat down. And I never said a word to her. I never got up and gave her a hug. I never got up and said I'm sorry about what has happened. I said nothing. Because I was-- it was like, we were in our assigned roles, sort of. And I deeply regretted that as a human being. I felt that was a failure of my own.
对话的另一位参与者。我们被叫到那里，我想，是作为反堕胎和支持堕胎选择立场的代表。然而，在节目开始前，尼基和我在同一个候机室准备上电视。她和她的丈夫在一起。我进来坐下了。我一句话也没对她说。我没有站起来拥抱她。我没有站起来说我对发生的事情感到抱歉。我什么也没说。因为我当时……就像，我们被困在了分配好的角色里，某种程度上。作为一个人类，我对此深感遗憾。我觉得那是我的失职。
Later, after we began this dialogue, but while it was still secret, I ran into Nicki at a State House hearing. I think it was a judiciary committee hearing. And there were a lot of people from both sides in the audience that day. And she walked by me and she tugged my sleeve, as if to say, you don't have to acknowledge that I'm here. But I'm just saying hi. So I turned around and did acknowledge her. Because I said, I'm not going to have that failing twice. And a couple of people had come up to me and said, you know Nicki Nichols Gamble? And I was able to say, actually, she's a very lovely person.
后来，在我们开始对话之后，但还在保密期间，我在州议会听证会上遇到了尼基。我想那是一次司法委员会听证会。那天观众席里有很多来自双方的人。她走过我身边，拉了拉我的袖子，仿佛是在说，你不必承认我在这里。但我只是打个招呼。所以我转过身来，确实承认了她。因为我说，我不想让那种失败发生两次。有几个人走过来对我说，你认识尼基·尼科尔斯·甘布尔吗？我能够回答说，事实上，她是一个非常可爱的人。
And it was shocking to some people, as it probably would have been to me before this all began. So I said, you know, we're never going to move the issue forward if we don't talk about it in a civilized way publicly.
这对有些人来说很令人震惊，正如在这一切开始之前它可能对我来说也会令人震惊一样。所以我说，你知道，如果我们不在公共场合文明地谈论这个问题，我们就永远无法推动问题的解决。
OK, so they're are all getting along so well. They have this amazing dialogue, the kind of thing, really, that seems to never, ever, usually happen. Did it nudge any of their views about abortion? Well again, here's Peter Coleman.
好的，所以她们相处得很好。她们进行了这场惊人的对话，这种事情，真的，似乎从来、从来没有发生过。它是否推动了她们对堕胎的任何看法？好吧，再一次，这是彼得·科尔曼的看法。
To me, one of the more fascinating things about what happened is that, through these conversations, the relationships got thicker. The relationships got more nuanced and more caring. And they became more polarized on the issue of pro-life, pro-choice.
对我来说，关于发生的事情最迷人的一点是，通过这些谈话，关系变得更深厚了。关系变得更加微妙和充满关怀。而在反堕胎和支持堕胎选择的问题上，她们变得更加两极分化。
So what does that mean, more polarized?
那是什么意思，更加两极分化？
It means that they became more certain that their point of view on the issue was right and that the other point of view on the issue, from the other side, was wrong.
这意味着她们更加确定自己在该问题上的观点是正确的，而对方在该问题上的观点是错误的。
One of the women, Madeline McComish, explained that this way. She said, having to dig deep to explain your reasoning and why you believe what it is that you believe in a group like this, it forces you to crystallize your own views. And so, of course, you end up even more convinced about your side. And as a result of this, Peter Coleman says, where they ended up was--
其中一位女性，马德琳·麦科米什（Madeline McComish），以这种方式解释了这一点。她说，必须深入挖掘来解释你的推理以及为什么你相信你所相信的东西，在一个这样的群体中，它迫使你结晶自己的观点。所以，当然，你最终会更加确信你这一方。彼得·科尔曼说，作为结果，她们的结局是——
Even though they cared deeply about these women, they differed fundamentally on this issue.
即使她们深深关心这些女性，她们在这个问题上仍有着根本的分歧。
So is this a success or a failure?
所以这是成功还是失败？
Well, from where we sit, it's a complete success.
嗯，从我们的立场来看，这是一个彻底的成功。
How?
怎么说？
Because what did happen is that the rhetoric changed. The conversations that would happen publicly around abortion, around pro-life, pro-choice, lost a lot of the edge and the vitriol in the community that it had had prior to the shooting and prior to the dialogue process.
因为确实发生的事情是言论改变了。在社区中围绕堕胎、反堕胎和支持堕胎选择所进行的公开谈话，失去了枪击事件发生前和对话过程前那种尖锐和刻薄的色彩。
Because these women were leaders in those movements on both sides and--
因为这些女性是双方运动中的领导者，并且——
They consciously decided that part of what they had done is contribute to the conditions where an event like this could take place.
她们有意识地决定，她们所做的一部分事情就是助长了像这样事件发生的条件。
Empathy has its limits. People are not going to agree. And the best that we can hope for is, we'll just try to see each other as well-meaning people that we respect, and keep things from getting to the point where we are trying to out and out destroy each other.
同理心是有局限的。人们不会达成一致。我们所能希望的最好结果是，我们将尽量把彼此视为我们所尊重的善意之人，并防止事情发展到我们试图彻底摧毁彼此的地步。
Well, today on our program, we have two stories which show just how difficult that is, how difficult it is to keep on the path of respect. In each of these stories, there is a pair of nemeses who get incredibly close to solving their problems, to actually getting along a little bit. And then not only do they backtrack, they backtrack royally. It is fascinating to see how far they go in the other direction and how they flip on a dime from one position to the other.
嗯，今天在我们的节目中，我们有两个故事，展示了那是多么困难，保持尊重的道路是多么困难。在每一个故事中，都有一对宿敌，她们非常接近于解决她们的问题，真正开始和睦相处一点点。然后，她们不仅退缩了，而且退缩得非常彻底。看到她们在另一个方向上走得有多远，以及她们如何在一瞬间从一个立场转向另一个立场，是令人着迷的。
One of the two stories takes place in Eastern Europe. The other takes place in another land where the rivalries are ancient and heartfelt. I'm talking about suburban New Jersey.
这两个故事中的一个发生在东欧。另一个发生在另一个敌对关系古老而深刻的土地上。我说的是新泽西州的郊区。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act one, Solidarity For Never. Poland had one of those national events a few years ago that you would think would pull an entire country together. It was a tragedy. It was a plane accident in April 2010, where the Polish president, the first lady, the country's military leaders, dozens of officials and leading Polish writers and thinkers-- 96 six people-- all died when their plane crashed in Russia, killing everybody on board.
第一幕，永不团结。几年前，波兰发生了这样一件全国性事件，你本以为它会把整个国家团结在一起。那是一场悲剧。那是一场发生在2010年4月的飞机事故，波兰总统、第一夫人、该国的军事领导人、数十名官员以及波兰主要的作家和思想家——96人——在他们的飞机在俄罗斯坠毁时全部遇难，机上所有人丧生。
And from the outside, this was this horrifying thing to witness people go through, any country go through. But the more complicated thing was what happened inside Poland after the crash. Perhaps you've guessed where this is going. It did not pull the country together. It emphatically did not do that. Amy Drozdowska-McGuire is an American reporter who for the past several years has been living in Poland. She has that story.
从外部来看，目睹人们经历这一切，任何国家经历这一切，都是一件令人恐惧的事情。但更复杂的是坠机后波兰内部发生的事情。也许你已经猜到这是怎么回事了。它并没有把国家团结在一起。它坚决没有那样做。艾米·德罗兹多夫斯卡-麦奎尔（Amy Drozdowska-McGuire）是一位美国记者，过去几年一直住在波兰。她带来了那个故事。
To understand the incredibly odd things that happened after the crash, you have to understand that before the crash, Poland was a country divided. Split right in half. You started to hear people talk about Poland A and Poland B. Poland A is the wealthier half, less conservative and more educated, more urban and younger. All for being part of the European Union.
要理解坠机后发生的事情有多么奇怪，你必须明白，在坠机前，波兰是一个分裂的国家。一分为二。你开始听到人们谈论“波兰A”和“波兰B”。波兰A是较富裕的一半，不那么保守，受教育程度更高，更城市化，更年轻。他们全力支持成为欧盟的一部分。
Poland B is the eastern part of the country. Deeply Catholic and conservative. Older and poorer. The one suspicious of the EU and the influence of godless Western Europe.
波兰B是该国的东部地区。极其天主教化和保守。更年长、更贫穷。他们对欧盟以及无神论西欧的影响持怀疑态度。
Poland A sees Poland B as backwards. Poland B feels like it's the real Poland. And who are these snotty city people in their skinny jeans looking down on them? The split between Poland A and B was also a political split. And the biggest wedge between the two halves was the late president, Lech Kaczynski. Half of the country, Poland A, passionately hated him.
波兰A认为波兰B是落后的。波兰B觉得他们才是真正的波兰。而那些穿着紧身牛仔裤、瞧不起他们的时髦城里人又是谁呢？波兰A和B之间的分裂也是一种政治分裂。而两半之间最大的裂痕是已故总统莱赫·卡钦斯基（Lech Kaczynski）。该国的一半，波兰A，热烈地憎恨他。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
The potato, the midget. Napoleon, also, because of his height. Psychopath. Schizophrenic.
土豆、侏儒。拿破仑，也是因为他的身高。精神病患者。精神分裂症患者。
This is Dominik Taras. In this story, he's going to be the stand-in for Poland A. He's young, early twenties, born and raised in Warsaw. He's part of the Poland who couldn't stand Kaczynski, thought he was an international embarrassment. And so Poland A liked to embarrass him.
这是多米尼克·塔拉斯（Dominik Taras）。在这个故事中，他将作为波兰A的代表。他很年轻，二十出头，在华沙出生长大。他是波兰的一部分，无法忍受卡钦斯基，认为他是一个国际笑话。所以波兰A喜欢让他难堪。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Kazcka, or the duck. I mean, that's another name that we called him.
“鸭子”（Kazcka），或者说那只鸭子。我的意思是，那是我们叫他的另一个名字。
That last nickname's a play on Kaczynski's surname. Kazcka. A duck. Not a bird exactly befitting the figurehead of a nation that wants to be taken seriously. To Dominik and Poland A, Kaczynski was a blundering xenophobe, anti-EU, mired in the past and holding the country back from a future as part of the west.
那个最后的绰号是卡钦斯基姓氏的谐音。Kazcka。一只鸭子。这并不是一只适合那个想要被认真对待的国家元首的鸟。对多米尼克和波兰A来说，卡钦斯基是一个笨拙的排外主义者，反欧盟，沉浸在过去，阻碍了这个国家作为西方一部分的未来。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Speaking for the other half of Poland, that's Poland B, here's Ewa Stankiewicz. She's a filmmaker and activist in her early forties. Tall but slight, with this definite weariness about her. She wears a necklace with a small delicate cross. And she didn't appreciate those Poland A types mocking and humiliating Kaczynski.
代表波兰另一半的，也就是波兰B，这里是埃娃·斯坦基维茨（Ewa Stankiewicz）。她是一位四十出头的电影制作人和活动家。高挑但清瘦，带着明显的疲惫感。她戴着一条带有精致小十字架的项链。她不喜欢那些波兰A类型的人嘲笑和羞辱卡钦斯基。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
They made fun of him as much as they could. They took his dignity away from him during his lifetime, but millions of Poles respected him. He was a statesman who was a great patriot.
他们尽可能地嘲弄他。他们在他的有生之年剥夺了他的尊严，但数百万波兰人尊重他。他是一位伟大的爱国政治家。
For Poland B people like Ewa, Kaczynski was a hero. The defender of pure Polishness and national sovereignty in a time when EU integration was starting to threaten that. Kaczynski was their savior.
对于像埃娃这样的波兰B人来说，卡钦斯基是英雄。在欧盟一体化开始威胁到这一点的时候，他是纯粹波兰性和国家主权的捍卫者。卡钦斯基是他们的救星。
Following the crash, it was as if the whole division between Poland A and Poland B just disappeared. You'd hear it everywhere. On the street, on TV. Slogans like, Let's Be One. Time to Stand Together. And these were people from two Polands. People who just days earlier would have told you themselves, they kind of hated each other.
坠机后，仿佛波兰A和波兰B之间的整个分裂就消失了。你到处都能听到。在街上，在电视上。像“让我们合而为一”、“现在是团结一致的时候了”这样的口号。而这些人来自两个波兰。就在几天前还会亲口告诉你他们有点互相憎恨的人。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
I felt a unity between Poles. A unity within the grief and the pain. And that we were living through it together. I felt a closeness between people. And for the first time I felt-- I don't know how to call it-- but perhaps a feeling of patriotism.
我感受到了波兰人之间的统一。在悲伤和痛苦中的统一。而且我们正在共同经历这一切。我感受到了人与人之间的亲近。而且我第一次感受到——我不知道该怎么称呼它——但这可能是一种爱国主义的感觉。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
It really showed people how to be patriotic. It was almost-- everyone came together. I must admit, actually, it's the first time I've ever seen anything like this.
它确实向人们展示了如何爱国。它几乎是——每个人都聚集在一起。我必须承认，实际上，这是我第一次看到这样的场景。
For Dominik, the memory that sticks out the most from this time was the day the country sounded the air raid sirens, signaling the whole nation to stop everything and remember Kaczynski and the other crash victims. Remember, this is for the man half the country hated. Including Dominik.
对于多米尼克来说，从那时起最深刻的记忆是国家拉响防空警报的那一天，示意整个国家停下手中一切事务，悼念卡钦斯基和其他坠机遇难者。请记住，这是为了那个半个国家都憎恨的人。包括多米尼克在内。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
It was absolutely everyone. Just everyone came to a standstill. I was actually riding my scooter at the time. So while all the cars around me-- while they were actually honking their horns in tune, or with the sirens at the same time-- I was there on my little scooter on the road. But I felt that I also had to honk my horn, even though it was a tiny scooter. So it really wasn't a match for the cars. But I thought I had to do it.
绝对是所有人。就每个人都停了下来。我当时实际上正骑着我的踏板车。所以当周围所有的汽车——当它们实际上在鸣喇叭，或同时拉响警笛时——我正骑着我的小踏板车在路上。但我感觉我也必须鸣喇叭，尽管它是一辆很小的踏板车。所以它确实比不上汽车。但我认为我必须那样做。
The grief that was reuniting Poland had a center, the presidential palace in Warsaw, sort of like the Polish White House. After the crash, people came there from all over the country, people from Poland A and Poland B. And they held vigil outside the gates for hours at a time. They brought flowers and candles and laid them on the sidewalk in front of the palace. Pretty soon, they completely filled the street.
重新凝聚波兰的悲伤有一个中心，就是华沙的总统府，有点像波兰的白宫。坠机后，全国各地的人们来到那里，来自波兰A和波兰B的人们。他们一次在门外守夜数小时。他们带来了花和蜡烛，摆在总统府前的人行道上。很快，他们完全填满了街道。
A few days after the plane crash, the Polish scouts-- they're like the Polish Boy Scouts-- added their own tribute to the sea of flowers and candles, a cross. It was a simple structure, standing about 12 feet high, without color or any ornamentation, made by hand out of wood.
飞机坠毁几天后，波兰童子军——他们就像波兰的男童军——在花海和蜡烛中增添了他们自己的致敬，一个十字架。这是一个简单的结构，高约12英尺，没有颜色或任何装饰，由木头手工制成。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Now in Polish culture, the cross has a history which is more than a thousand years old.
现在在波兰文化中，十字架有着一千多年以上的历史。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Putting a cross there is actually quite a good idea. You have to remember that the cross in our culture is very close to the nation. It's close to our history.
在那里放一个十字架实际上是一个相当好的主意。你必须记住，在我们文化中，十字架非常接近这个国家。它接近我们的历史。
The cross is our identity. It's our culture.
十字架就是我们的身份。它是我们的文化。
Everyone from around was, we're going there. And it was kind of a duty of every Pole to do that. I mean, this man was our president, no matter which way you look at it. So going there, putting your flowers or wreath down, lighting a candle, this is the way that it should have happened.
周围的每个人都说，我们要去那里。这几乎是每个波兰人的义务。我的意思是，这个人是我们的总统，无论你怎么看。所以去那里，放下你的花或花圈，点上一支蜡烛，这就是事情本该发生的方式。
Pretty soon, this 12-foot wooden cross became the centerpiece of the entire nation's grief. You'd see the coverage of all the people there on that street, those huge crowds of mourners, and always in the center of the frame was the cross.
很快，这个12英尺高的木制十字架成为了整个国家悲伤的核心。你会看到在那条街上所有人的报道，那些巨大的哀悼人群，而且画面中心总是那个十字架。
It didn't take too long, though-- just three days, in fact-- before all this unity started to crack. It was like the end of a long family holiday dinner, when tensions finally start to flare, and the same old arguments come out. Kaczynski's family had declared their wish that he be buried at Wawel Castle Cathedral in Krakow. And the church gave its consent. Wawel is kind of like the Polish Westminster, where the country's saints, kings, and national heroes are entombed.
不过，没过多久——事实上仅仅三天——这种团结就开始破裂了。这就像是一顿漫长的家庭假日晚餐的结束，紧张局势终于开始爆发，同样的陈年旧账又被提了出来。卡钦斯基的家人表示希望他被安葬在克拉科夫的瓦维尔城堡大教堂。教会对此表示同意。瓦维尔有点像波兰的威斯敏斯特大教堂，该国的圣人、国王和民族英雄都安葬于此。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
So with the Wawel, that's how it all started. The moment when they announced that they were going to bury the presidential couple at the Wawel Cathedral, that's when Poles just kind of split up. The [BLEEP] hit the fan. That's when it all started.
所以关于瓦维尔，一切就是这样开始的。当他们宣布要将总统夫妇葬在瓦维尔大教堂的那一刻，波兰人就以某种方式分裂了。一切都搞砸了。一切就是从那时开始的。
To get why this caused such a huge uproar, why Dominik and the rest of Poland A freaked out about this, I have to underline that the kind of people buried at Wawel are the stuff of legends, like kings who slay dragons, saints who performed miracles. So imagine the reaction when they announced that President Kaczynski and his wife Maria would be buried at Wawel. It was like Poland A woke up and remembered, wait a minute. We can't stand Kaczynski.
为了理解为什么这引起了如此巨大的骚乱，为什么多米尼克和波兰A的其他成员为此抓狂，我必须强调，埋葬在瓦维尔的人都是传奇人物，比如屠龙的国王，创造奇迹的圣人。所以想象一下当他们宣布卡钦斯基总统和他的妻子玛丽亚将被葬在瓦维尔时的反应。就像波兰A醒了过来并记起，等一下。我们无法忍受卡钦斯基。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
It was a joke. I really couldn't believe it. We all thought it was a joke. I would have thought that Wawel, you know, a place which is holy for all Poles-- I mean, it's a symbol of Polish history-- It's holy. It's untouchable. I mean, we all thought that the Wawel's closed. I mean, there's no more room to put any more people inside there, down in the catacombs. Suddenly, there's room for Kaczynski. So Kaczynski being buried in the Wawel, it's like he was rewriting the history books. And it's just amazing to think that the decision of one man is able to ruin a thousand years of this heritage by deciding to bury Kaczynski there.
这简直是个笑话。我真的不敢相信。我们都认为这是一个玩笑。我本以为瓦维尔，你知道，一个对所有波兰人来说神圣的地方——我的意思是，它是波兰历史的一个象征——它是神圣的。它是不可触碰的。我的意思是，我们都认为瓦维尔已经关闭了。我的意思是，地下的墓穴里再也没有空间安置更多的人了。突然间，有卡钦斯基的位置了。所以卡钦斯基被葬在瓦维尔，就像他在改写历史书。想到一个人的决定竟然能够通过决定将卡钦斯基葬在那里来毁掉一千年的这种遗产，真是太神奇了。
In the end, on April 23, 13 days after the crash, the late president and his wife were laid to rest at Wawel. So Poland A lost that first round. If the whole Wawel thing was a slap in the face of Poland A, the thing that set off Poland B was the election to replace Kaczynski.
最终，在坠机13天后的4月23日，已故总统和他的妻子被安葬在瓦维尔。所以波兰A输掉了第一回合。如果说整个瓦维尔事件是给波兰A的一记耳光，那么激怒波兰B的是取代卡钦斯基的选举。
In the election, Poland B's candidate was-- I'm not kidding you-- the late president's identical twin brother, Jaroslaw Kaczynski. If you were with Poland B, you could vote for not just your beloved president's political heir, not just his flesh and blood brother, but a guy who looked exactly like him. Even their own mother could never tell them apart.
在选举中，波兰B的候选人是——我没在开玩笑——已故总统的同卵双胞胎兄弟，雅罗斯瓦夫·卡钦斯基（Jaroslaw Kaczynski）。如果你是波兰B阵营的，你不止可以投票给你敬爱的总统的政治继承人，不止他的亲生骨肉兄弟，而且是一个长得和他一模一样的人。即使他们自己的母亲也分不清他们。
Poland A's choice was Bronislaw Komorowski, the former parliamentary speaker, the guy who had taken over as acting head of state after the plane crash. The race was nail-bitingly close. But at the final count, Bronislaw Komorowski, Poland A's choice, won.
波兰A的选择是布罗尼斯瓦夫·科莫罗夫斯基（Bronislaw Komorowski），前议会议长，坠机后接任代理国家元首的人。选情极其胶着。但在最后的计票中，布罗尼斯瓦夫·科莫罗夫斯基，波兰A的选择，赢了。
For Poland A, this was like the restart the country needed to start moving on and get back to business. But for Poland B, this was a huge blow. Not only was their hero dead. But now, they had lost the power too.
对于波兰A来说，这就像是国家重新开始以继续前进并恢复正常运作所需要的重启。但对于波兰B来说，这是一个巨大的打击。不仅他们的英雄死了。而且现在，他们也失去了权力。
By the time of the election, for weeks on end, day and night, Poland B had been holding vigil at the cross. Even after the funeral was long over, even after the period of national mourning had officially ended, the crowds at the presidential palace never stopped. Week after week, the flowers and candles continued to fill the street and pile up around the wooden cross. And Ewa Stankiewicz was there from the start, nearly round the clock filming it all, talking with the people there.
到选举时，连续几周，日日夜夜，波兰B一直在这个十字架前守夜。即使葬礼早已结束，即使全国哀悼期已正式结束，总统府门前的人群从未停止。一周又一周，鲜花和蜡烛继续填满街道并堆积在木制十字架周围。而埃娃·斯坦基维茨从一开始就在那里，几乎全天候拍摄这一切，与那里的人们交谈。
This is from her footage, which she has released as two films, Solidarity 2010 and The Cross .
这是来自她的素材，她已将其发布为两部纪录片，《团结2010》和《十字架》。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Ewa filmed men and women standing out in the rain at 3:00 AM to keep the vigil going. People with tears in their eyes, talking about their grief and loss.
埃娃拍摄了凌晨3点站在雨中的男女，以保持守夜活动。人们眼中含着泪水，谈论着他们的悲伤和失落。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
And then, after just a few days, things started to shift. When you watch the interviews, you start to see this hint of something different in the faces of people. That shift from composed sadness to something closer to fear, and an edge that starts to underline their voices. There's this one word that starts coming up and keeps coming up. Zamach, assassination.
然后，仅仅几天后，情况开始转变。当你观看采访时，你开始看到人们脸上有某种不同迹象的暗示。从镇定的悲伤转变到更接近恐惧的东西，以及开始在他们的声音中凸显的尖锐。有一个词开始出现，并且不断出现：Zamach，暗杀。
People start bringing up the idea that the plane crash was no accident. And the dark figure looming behind all this fear is Russia. They were behind all this. If anyone has reasons to not trust the Russians, Poland's got them. More than a century of war and brutal occupation by Russia. Communism and the unrelenting paranoia of living in a police state. Those kinds of reasons.
人们开始提出飞机坠毁不是意外的想法。而在这个恐惧背后若隐若现的阴影是俄罗斯。是他们在背后指使这一切。如果说有人有理由不信任俄罗斯人，波兰人就有。超过一个世纪的战争和俄罗斯的残酷占领。共产主义和生活在警察国家中的不懈偏执。那些就是理由。
For Poland A, though, this is history. And they're all about looking forward. Whereas for Poland B, this is all very much alive. For them, Russia is still a threat.
然而对波兰A来说，这是历史。他们一心向前看。而对于波兰B来说，这一切依然非常鲜活。对他们而言，俄罗斯仍然是一个威胁。
This is actually a huge part of why Poland B loves the late president Kaczynski. He was a hardliner when it came to Russia. As a matter of fact, he wouldn't even speak with Russians, wouldn't be in the same room with them. He was Poland B's anti-Russian hero. And the new president, Poland A's Komorowski, was in league with the enemy.
这实际上是波兰B热爱已故卡钦斯基总统的很大一部分原因。在俄罗斯问题上，他是个强硬派。事实上，他甚至不会与俄罗斯人交谈，不会与他们待在同一个房间里。他是波兰B的反俄英雄。而新总统，波兰A的科莫罗夫斯基，与敌人狼狈为奸。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
They saw him as a kind of Russian envoy, a spy, someone who isn't worthy of becoming president of Poland, who actually has no moral right to become president of Poland.
他们视他为某种俄罗斯特使、间谍，一个不配成为波兰总统的人，他实际上没有任何道德权利成为波兰总统。
At one point, Poland B people actually started spreading this weird rumor. That Komorowski wasn't a real Pole. That actually, he was descended from a murdering Bolshevik grandfather who slit the throats of the real Komorowskis and usurped the family name. So the new president wasn't even Polish. He was secretly Russian.
有一次，波兰B的人甚至开始传播这个奇怪的谣言。说科莫罗夫斯基不是真正的波兰人。事实上，他是从一位杀人犯布尔什维克祖父那里传下来的，那个祖父割断了真正科莫罗夫斯基家族人的喉咙并篡夺了家族名号。所以新总统甚至不是波兰人。他秘密地是俄罗斯人。
And if that sounds nuts to you, that Russia would have killed the Polish president, here's how the facts lined up for the Poles. The plane crash happened in Russia. And even more than that, the plane full of all those Polish elite-- political leaders, financial heads, writers-- they were on their way to commemorate the massacre of another group of Polish elite in the Second World War. More than 20,000 murdered in the woods. And the whole thing covered up for decades.
如果这种想法对你来说很疯狂，即俄罗斯会杀掉波兰总统，以下是事实对波兰人的排列方式。坠机发生在俄罗斯。不仅如此，那架载满波兰精英的飞机——政治领导人、金融首脑、作家——他们正在前往纪念第二次世界大战中另一群波兰精英被屠杀的路上。超过20,000人在森林中被谋杀。而且这一切被掩盖了几十年。
Also, remember the trauma of their history with Russia is very recent. Moscow controlled Poland until 1989. So this idea that the Russians were at it again seemed entirely plausible to lots of people. Even a Poland A guy like Dominik told me, sure, he thinks the plane crash was just an unfortunate accident. But listen, a lot of crazy stuff went down during communism. It's a perfectly reasonable thing to think the Russians might be behind it.
另外，请记住他们与俄罗斯历史的创伤非常近期。莫斯科控制波兰直到1989年。所以俄罗斯人又故伎重演的想法在很多人看来似乎完全合理。即使是像多米尼克这样的波兰A阵营的人也告诉我，当然，他认为坠机只是不幸的事故。但听着，共产主义期间发生了很多疯狂的事情。认为俄罗斯人可能在背后主使是一个完全合理的想法。
Though Poland B didn't stop with a few reasonable suspicions. You started to hear elaborate conspiracy theories and secret plots to destroy the nation.
虽然波兰B并没有止步于几个合理的怀疑。你开始听到关于摧毁国家的详尽阴谋论和秘密阴谋。
Like any group rallying around a cause, Poland B adopted a symbol, the cross. That simple wooden cross the Polish Boy Scouts put up had officially become the symbol of their country in crisis. All their grief, all their fear, went into those wooden beams. It was a bit like when the cross became the symbol of a free Poland during solidarity in the '80s. A symbol for the country's united fight against the communists. This time, though, the Poland B people by the cross felt abandoned, turned on by their own countrymen. While Poland A, everybody else, was starting to feel uncomfortable, impatient.
就像任何围绕一个事业集结的群体一样，波兰B采取了一个象征，即十字架。波兰童子军竖立的那个简单的木制十字架已正式成为他们处于危机中的国家的象征。他们所有的悲伤、所有的恐惧都注入了那些木梁中。这有点像80年代团结工会期间十字架成为自由波兰的象征。一个国家联合起来反抗共产主义者的象征。然而这一次，十字架旁的波兰B人感到被遗弃，被自己的同胞背叛。而波兰A，其他人，开始感到不安、不耐烦。
With Poland A and Poland B starting to go after each other again, things there in front of the cross were starting to get ugly. Violence started happening, at first in small ways. Drunk young people would stumble out of the nearby bars in the area and mock the Poland B people praying by the cross. They'd curse them out, or even physically attack them.
随着波兰A和波兰B开始再次攻击对方，十字架前的事情开始变得丑陋。暴力开始发生，起初是以小规模的方式。醉酒的年轻人会从附近酒吧里摇摇晃晃走出来，嘲弄在十字架旁祈祷的波兰B人。他们会咒骂他们，甚至进行身体攻击。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
There was an example of a young man who kicked a woman. I don't think she'd even been praying for a very long time, but a lot of passers by knelt down to pray as they passed. And I think she was one of those. There was another incident of a woman who was pushed. And she fell. And she nearly cracked open her head on the pavement. There were incidents of people putting out their cigarettes on the necks of people.
有一个例子，一个年轻人踢了一名妇女。我不认为她已经祈祷了很长时间，但许多路人经过时会跪下祈祷。我想她是其中之一。还有另一起事件，一名妇女被推倒。她摔倒了。她的头差点在人行道上磕开。还有人把烟头熄灭在人们脖子上的事件。
Dominik and Poland A, though, saw this violence differently. The way he saw it, it was the cross people who were out of control. They were embarrassing, hostile. And it was starting to seem like they were never going to leave.
然而，多米尼克和波兰A以不同的方式看待这种暴力。在他看来，是十字架那边的人失去了控制。他们令人尴尬、敌对。而且看起来他们永远不会离开。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
I didn't want to go there. I mean, the atmosphere was just too aggressive. I mean, you would go there, and you would immediately be accused of being a spy or being sent by Moscow to be there or something. There was even an anecdote going around at that time about the cross, that even if Jesus had come for the cross, they would have said, what are you doing here, you Jew? Get out of here.
我不想去那里。我的意思是，气氛太具有攻击性了。我的意思是，你会去那里，你会立即被指责为间谍，或者被莫斯科派来这里之类的。当时甚至有一个关于十字架的轶事流传，即使耶稣来到这个十字架前，他们也会说，你在这干什么，你这个犹太佬？滚开。
You see, this is when Poland A started to feel like it was time, time for those hostile people to stop camping out in a public street day and night like they owned the place, to take down the giant cross standing in front of a secular government building.
你看，这就是波兰A开始觉得是时候了，是时候让那些敌对的人停止在公共街道上日夜露营，好像那里是他们家一样，是时候拆掉立在世俗政府大楼前的那个巨型十字架了。
The plan to take away the cross was careful, diplomatic. It would be done with the utmost respect. It would be taken to a place of honor, the nearby Church of St. Anne. The right people would be there to do the job-- Catholic priests, church leaders, and Polish Boy Scouts-- the very people who had put the cross there in the first place.
拆除十字架的计划谨慎而外交。它将以最尊重的态度进行。它将被带到一个尊荣的地方，附近的圣安妮教堂。合适的人将去完成这项工作——天主教牧师、教会领袖和波兰童子军——正是当初竖立十字架的那些人。
So with that plan in place, the day came to take down the cross. And on that day, all hell broke loose.
所以随着该计划到位，拆除十字架的日子到了。而在那一天，局面彻底失控。
Truckloads of police were there. Thousands of protesters pushing against the barricades erected around the cross. They were chanting and holding signs that said, "If you're a Pole, then come with us," and "Komorowski, traitor of the state," and "It's our cross. It's our cross."
警车装载着警察到了那里。成千上万的抗议者推挤着立在十字架周围的栅栏。他们高喊着，手里拿着标语，写着“如果你是波兰人，就和我们站在一起”、“科莫罗夫斯基，国家叛徒”和“这是我们的十字架，这是我们的十字架”。
At one point, a woman tied herself to the cross with rope and started shouting that the cross is a symbol of the 96 people who died in the catastrophe, that we won't let it be taken away. When the priests and scouts showed up, people started screaming at them. They chanted, defend the cross. And shouted at them, calling them "Judas, Judas" and "Gestapo." Keep in mind, these were the conservative, older, very Catholic people of Poland B shouting Judas at priests who were there to move a cross, calling them Nazis.
有一次，一名妇女用绳子把自己绑在十字架上，开始大喊十字架是96名在灾难中丧生的人的象征，我们不会让它被带走。当牧师和童子军出现时，人们开始对着他们尖叫。他们高喊着，“捍卫十字架”。并对他们大吼，称他们为“犹大，犹大”和“盖世太保”。请记住，这些是波兰B的保守、年长、非常天主教化的人，对着在那里移动十字架的牧师高喊犹大，称他们为纳粹。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
The key thing for me, which really got me angry, was the fact that they were offending scouts and priests. I mean, these are people for the public good. So why are these people being shouted at and slandered? Only someone without a soul or a mind could do something like this. You'd have to be, really, kind of an animal to be throwing such slanderous comments at these people who are only doing good for other people in the world.
对我来说最关键的事情，真正让我生气的是，他们冒犯了童子军和牧师。我的意思是，这些人是为公共利益服务的。那么，为什么这些人会被高声喝骂和诽谤？只有灵魂或头脑缺失的人才会做出这种事情。你必须是一个真正的动物，才会对这些仅仅是在为世界上其他人做善事的人，投掷如此诽谤性的评论。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
The scouts were totally disorientated. They had tears in their eyes. And the people started calling out to them and to the priests not to do it, not to take the cross away. And they asked the priests to start praying with them. And the people started praying. And the priests joined them in prayer.
童子军完全迷失了方向。他们眼中含着泪水。人们开始对他们和牧师大喊，不要这样做，不要把十字架带走。他们要求牧师和他们一起祈祷。于是人们开始祈祷。牧师加入了他们的祈祷。
Some people started pushing through the police barriers put up for the occasion. And police tried to push them back. Then the police brought out the pepper spray and things got even more nuts.
有些人开始冲破为该场合设立的警察防线。警察试图把他们推回去。然后警察拿出了辣椒喷雾，事情变得更加疯狂。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
You could see these granddads going at fisticuffs with the other people. You've got grandmothers, elderly women, beating people with their walking sticks, almost. They broke through the barriers and they were rallying people to come and defend the cross. You know, come with us.
你可以看到这些祖父辈的人在和其他人打拳头架。你有祖母辈的，老年妇女，几乎是用她们的拐杖打人。她们冲破了防线，她们在召集人们来捍卫十字架。你知道，跟我们一起来。
Things got so out of control that, in the end, the government officials in charge of the operation had to call the whole thing off. The cross stayed put. It's not what happened that day they tried to take the cross that really surprised me, that shocked me into seeing a meanness within the country that I didn't think existed, was possible, that really brought out the very worst in people. It was what happened after. When Dominik Taras, pulling for Poland A, threw a party, a huge Facebook-led event attended by thousands. Those Poland A people who said to Poland B, if you're going to pull a protest like that, fine. Then we're going to protest your protest.
事情失去了控制，最终，负责行动的政府官员不得不取消了整个行动。十字架留在了那里。并不是试图拆除十字架的那天发生的事情真正让我感到惊讶，让我震惊到看到了一个我没想到存在、可能存在的国家内部的卑劣，真正激发出人们最坏的一面。是后来发生的事情。当支持波兰A的多米尼克·塔拉斯举办了一场派对，一个由Facebook引导的数千人参加的巨大活动。那些对波兰B说，如果你要进行那样的抗议，没关系。那我们就要抗议你们的抗议。
It was the exact opposite of all this angry unyielding earnestness. They dressed up as sumo wrestlers, put on Star Wars costumes, and danced there in the streets in front of the cross defenders. They tossed around a beach ball. They did the wave. They blew bubbles and sang children's nursery rhymes. They waved around signs like, "Take down the presidential palace. It's getting in the way of the cross."
这与所有这些愤怒、不可屈服的认真态度完全相反。他们装扮成相扑选手，穿上星球大战服装，在十字架捍卫者面前的街道上跳舞。他们抛掷沙滩球。他们做了人浪。他们吹肥皂泡，唱着儿歌。他们挥舞着标语，写着“拆除总统府，它挡住了十字架的道”。
But then it changed. It stopped being so light-hearted. It felt more like one group mocking another's most sincere beliefs, their deepest fears. Like when I saw a bunch of Poland A people parading around a cross made out of beer cans and another person dressed up as a bishop in robes made out of toilet paper. And then the duck came out.
但后来它变了。它不再那么轻松了。它感觉更像是一个群体嘲笑另一个群体最真诚的信仰、他们最深层的恐惧。比如当我看到一群波兰A的人游行，抬着一个用啤酒罐做成的十字架，还有另一个人装扮成主教，穿着卫生纸做成的长袍。然后鸭子出来了。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
I mean, that was like, a cuddly toy in the shape of a duck, right? A nice allusion to the surname of the Kaczynski brothers.
我的意思是，那就像，一只鸭子形状的毛绒玩具，对吧？对卡钦斯基兄弟姓氏的一个很好的影射。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Kaczka, which means duck in Polish. And this duck was tossed around like a football. And ripped apart.
“鸭子”（Kaczka），在波兰语中意味着鸭子。而这只鸭子被像足球一样抛来抛去。并被撕成了碎片。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
It was quite emotional, I would say. This duck was being kind of tossed around. And then suddenly someone grabbed it and ripped off a leg here and ripped off a leg there. And by the end of it, the whole thing was in shreds and all the filling was up in the air. Like all the feathers from the inside-- this kind of guts-- were floating around in the air.
我会说这相当情绪化。这只鸭子被抛来抛去。然后突然有人抓住了它，撕下了这里的一条腿，撕下了那里的一条腿。最终，整个东西变成了碎片，所有的填充物都在空中飞扬。就像里面的所有羽毛——这种内脏——在空中飘浮。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
People were shouting, one more, one more. Which meant that they were calling for the death of the second Kaczynski, his brother.
人们在喊着，再来一个，再来一个。这意味着他们在呼唤第二个卡钦斯基，也就是他的兄弟的死亡。
Well, that's her interpretation of one more. Dominik saw it another way.
嗯，那是她对“再来一个”的解读。多米尼克以另一种方式看待它。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
Give us one more. Give us one more. And then, someone just threw another one in there.
给我们再来一个。给我们再来一个。然后，有人只是把另一个扔进了那里。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[波兰语讲话]
It felt terrible to wish death onto someone. It's not something I'd wish on my worst enemy.
祝愿某人死亡感觉太可怕了。这不是我会祝愿我最坏敌人的事情。
Let me just say here, I'm of Polish descent. I've lived in Poland off and on for a few years now. And this is where I felt like, I didn't know this country anymore. For me, Poland's a tough love kind of place. Grandmothers yelling at you to dress your kid more warmly. Hard on itself. But deeply sincere. Decent.
让我在这里说一下，我有波兰血统。我在波兰断断续续住了几年了。而这就是我感到我不再了解这个国家的地方。对我来说，波兰是一个“严厉的爱”的地方。祖母们大喊大叫让你给孩子穿暖和点。对自己很苛刻。但极其真诚。体面。
Where the local version of the TV show Big Brother never really took off because Poles thought it was mean in a way that made them uncomfortable. Their version of So You Think You Can Dance is You Can Dance . It's like, in the end, they want to watch each other succeed. Not tear each other down.
电视节目《老大哥》的本地版本从未真正火起来，因为波兰人认为这太刻薄，让他们感到不舒服。《舞林争霸》的波兰版本叫做《你会跳舞》（You Can Dance）。我的意思是，最终，他们想看彼此成功。而不是互相拆台。
And I always thought this Poland A, Poland B thing was an anomaly. Something they'd all get over. Post-communist growing pains. But it's just started to occur to me that maybe this is what post-communist means. This is democracy. They traded a common enemy and a common cause for a system that pits them against their fellow citizens and turns their own countrymen into their worst enemies.
我一直认为这个波兰A、波兰B的事情是一个反常现象。某种他们都会克服的事情。后共产主义的成长烦恼。但这刚开始让我觉得，也许这就是后共产主义的含义。这就是民主。他们用一个共同的敌人和一个共同的事业，换取了一个让本国公民彼此对立、并把他们自己的同胞变成最坏敌人的制度。
That whole thing about coming together after a tragedy, that tragedy brings people closer together, that it brings out their best? It can work the other way too. It can bring out the worst and drive people apart. Especially when it's your own country, your family. Your family, your own countrymen, they're the ones who have the real power to destroy you.
关于在悲剧发生后走到一起，悲剧让人们更亲近，它激发出他们最好的一面，这整个事情？它也可能朝另一个方向发展。它能激发出最坏的一面并使人们分裂。特别是当它是你自己的国家，你的家庭时。你的家庭，你自己的同胞，他们才是真正有能力摧毁你的人。
Komorowski kept trying to come up with ideas to take down the cross, Offered compromises, all of which were shot down. At one point, he tried a plaque, one that honored Lech Kaczynski and all the victims of the plane crash. They put it right on the outside front wall of the presidential palace. The plaque itself even had a good-sized cross on it. Defenders of the cross were not impressed. A 71-year-old man threw a jar of his own feces at it.
科莫罗夫斯基一直试图想出拆除十字架的想法，提出妥协，但所有妥协都被拒绝了。有一次，他尝试了一块牌匾，那块牌匾纪念莱赫·卡钦斯基和坠机事件的所有遇难者。他们把它直接放在总统府外面的正面墙上。牌匾本身甚至还有一个相当大的十字架。十字架的捍卫者们并不买账。一名71岁的老人向它投掷了一罐自己的排泄物。
In the end, the cross simply disappeared. In the wee hours of a Thursday morning in late September, guards quietly and unceremoniously came to the cross, took it down, and carried it inside the palace, before anybody realized what was happening, before anyone could stop them. A non-event. It's now finally at the Church of St. Anne, as originally planned.
最终，十字架消失了。在9月下旬的一个星期四凌晨，守卫们悄悄且没有任何仪式地来到十字架前，把它拆下来，带进总统府，在任何人意识到发生了什么之前，在任何人能阻止他们之前。一个非事件。正如原计划，它现在最终安放在圣安妮教堂。
The two sides have continued in small ways to keep up the fight. Right where the cross stood at the palace, a group meets to pray every night at 9:00 PM. Ewa Stankiewicz is often with them. People are constantly leaving crosses. The authorities take them away, but people just bring more. Dominik told me there's even one on wheels that they pull around, bring out, hide, bring it out again. To this empty space in front of a government building that people are still trying to fill.
双方继续以小规模的方式保持斗争。就在十字架立在总统府的地方，一群人每天晚上9点在那里祈祷。埃娃·斯坦基维茨经常和他们在一起。人们不断地留下十字架。当局把它们拿走，但人们只是带了更多来。多米尼克告诉我，甚至还有一个带轮子的，他们拉着它四处走动，拿出来，藏起来，再拿出来。到政府大楼前这个人们仍然试图填补的空地上。
Amy Drozdowska-McGuire in Warsaw.
来自华沙的艾米·德罗兹多夫斯卡-麦奎尔。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Nemeses, stories of seemingly intractable long-term conflicts. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, A Tale of Two Jerseys.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，宿敌，关于看似棘手的长期冲突的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，两个泽西州的故事。
Chris Gethard was a freshman at Rutgers when this story took place, the story in which he discovered a nemesis he did not feel anything for at all, until suddenly he did feel something for, fiercely and fully. Rutgers is the state school of New Jersey. And Chris says that when he was there, back in 1998, it was, he says, kind of a low point for the university and for him.
克里斯·格哈德（Chris Gethard）在罗格斯大学读大一时发生了这个故事，在这个故事中，他发现了一个他根本没有任何感觉的宿敌，直到突然间，他对他产生了一种激烈且彻底的感觉。罗格斯是新泽西州的州立大学。克里斯说，当他在那里时，回到1998年，他说，那对大学和他自己来说，是一个低谷。
He says that they had started all kinds of construction projects to rebuild the campus, but, he says, they hadn't gotten very far. And buildings seemed to be just falling apart. He says his classes were terrible. It was hundreds of unmotivated kids in massive seminars. He was miserable. He takes it from here.
他说他们开始了一切类型的建设项目来重建校园，但是，他说，他们并没有取得多大进展。而建筑物看起来似乎只是在分崩离析。他说他的课程很糟糕。那是在大型研讨会中数百个没有动力的孩子。他很痛苦。他从这里接手。
Rutgers during my stay was both overcrowded and filthy. I lived in this tiny dorm room with this Estonian nationalist known as the Russian bear. And the view from our dorm was the Raritan River, which doesn't move. It's just like a streak of liquid malaria.
我待在罗格斯期间，它既过度拥挤又肮脏。我住在这个狭小的宿舍房间里，与一个被称为“俄罗斯熊”的爱沙尼亚民族主义者住在一起。我们宿舍的窗景是拉里坦河，它不流动。它就像一条液态疟疾的条纹。
The main reason I went there was because they didn't make me write an essay. And it just blew. It just was the worst. So I did what anybody who was a college freshman in 1998 would have done. I sat on the internet all day. Specifically, on the instant messenger program, where my name was Framsky.
我去那里的主要原因是他们没让我写文章。而且这真是太烂了。它就是最糟糕的。所以我做了任何一个在1998年上大学的人都会做的事情。我整天坐在互联网上。具体来说，是在即时通讯程序上，我的名字是Framsky。
And I really liked having that outlet because I could ignore and not deal with real-life outside my dorm room. And I could also control what people saw of me. I was doing anything and everything to avoid dealing with the reality of my actual existence. IM was my lifeline. Framsky was all I had.
而且我真的很喜欢有那个出口，因为我可以忽视并且不必处理我宿舍房间外面的真实生活。我也可以控制人们看到我什么。我正在做任何和所有的事情来避免处理我实际存在的现实。即时通讯是我的生命线。Framsky是我拥有的一切。
I was on Instant Messenger so much I would even IM with the kid who lived directly across the hall from me, a ridiculously tall half-Asian kid named Andy. And he was the same way. I still remember, we would instant message each other about how we didn't have any friends. I still, to this day, am like, why weren't he and I better friends?
我上即时通讯的时间太多了，以至于我甚至会和那个直接住在我宿舍对面、一个叫安迪的、特别高的混血亚裔孩子聊天。而他也是一样。我至今仍然记得，我们会通过即时通讯交流我们是如何没有朋友的。直到今天，我还觉得，为什么他和我没能成为更好的朋友呢？
One day I'm online and get this message from this guy. His name is Rob. He went to Princeton. He was a friend of some friends. I didn't really know him that well. But he sends me this message. It says, "Chris, watch out." And before I can ask why, over 30 messages from people I don't know pop up on my screen. And all those people start flagging me, reporting me to the program as if I've done something wrong. And suddenly, I was kicked off the system.
有一天我在线，收到这个家伙的消息。他的名字是罗伯。他去了普林斯顿。他是我们一些共同朋友的朋友。我其实不怎么认识他。但他发给我这个消息。他说：“克里斯，小心点。”在我还没来得及问为什么之前，超过30个我不认识的人发来的消息弹出在我的屏幕上。而那些人开始标记我，向程序报告我，就好像我做错了什么事情一样。突然间，我被踢出了系统。
Because if you used Instant Messenger back in the day, you'll remember, there weren't any rules. There was nothing written down that was like, you can't say or do the following. The way it worked was, if you were being a jerk, the person you were being a jerk to could warn you. And if that happened enough times, the system assumed you actually were being a jerk. And it booted you.
因为如果你在那个时代使用即时通讯，你会记得，没有任何规则。没有什么写下来的东西是像“你不能说或做以下事情”。它的运作方式是，如果你是个混蛋，你对他表现得像个混蛋的那个人可以警告你。如果这种情况发生了足够多次，系统就会假设你确实是个混蛋。然后它就把你踢了。
I was cut off immediately. And I was filled with rage. I know it's stupid, but that was my breaking point. I was just like, I'm done. I just can't.
我立刻被切断了联系。我充满了愤怒。我知道这很愚蠢，但这成了我的临界点。我只是觉得，我受够了。我就是不能。
So I called up that dude, Rob, and was like, "What was that?"
所以我给那个家伙罗伯打电话，问道：“那是什么？”
And he goes, "It's this kid. He lives on my floor here at Princeton. He's been doing that to people the past few days. He calls it IM-bombing. He thinks it's really funny."
他说：“是这个孩子。他住在普林斯顿我这一层楼。这几天他一直在对人们那样做。他称之为‘IM轰炸’。他认为这真的很有趣。”
And I'm like, "IM-bombing? What the hell?"
我说：“IM轰炸？那是什么鬼？”
And Rob says, "Yeah. He got your name off my computer. I didn't realize it until it was too late. Sorry. I tried to give you a heads up."
罗伯说：“是的。他从我的电脑上弄到了你的名字。我意识到时已经太晚了。抱歉。我试着给你提个醒。”
And I go, "What's this kid's name?"
我问他：“这个孩子叫什么名字？”
And Rob says, "He's a nice guy. His name is Amir."
罗伯说：“他是个好人。他叫阿米尔（Amir）。”
I asked him, like, "A-M-I-R?"
我像这样问他：“A-M-I-R？”
"Yeah," he said.
“是的，”他说。
"So his name is Amir, right?"
“所以他叫阿米尔，对吧？”
"Yeah," Rob said. "But he pronounces it Am-er."
“是的，”罗伯说。“但他发音成Am-er。”
And I was like, "Tell me more about him."
我说：“告诉我更多关于他的事。”
And Rob says, "I don't know. He's nice, man. He's from Toronto."
罗伯说：“我不知道。他是个好人，伙计。他来自多伦多。”
"From Toronto?" I said. He's [BLEEP] dead.
“来自多伦多？”我说。他死定了。
Not because I have anything against Canada, but I couldn't let someone from Canada come to Jersey, which is mine, and mess with me. I couldn't do that. I couldn't allow that. The fact that this guy went to Princeton, every Rutgers kid, every Jersey kid, he's going to hate him just a little bit. He went to Princeton. I mean, we're natural enemies.
不是因为我对加拿大有什么意见，但我不能让一个来自加拿大的人来到泽西州，那是我的领土，来戏弄我。我不能这样做。我不能允许那样。事实上，这家伙去了普林斯顿，每一个罗格斯的孩子，每一个泽西州的孩子，他都会稍微讨厌他一点。他去了普林斯顿。我的意思是，我们是天生的敌人。
"Rob, what's the name of your dorm?" I asked.
“罗伯，你们宿舍的名字叫什么？”我问。
Then, I took action. I threw open my door and saw Andy sitting with his door open across the hall. Andy was as depressed and crazy as I was. Plus he had a car.
然后，我采取了行动。我猛地打开我的门，看到安迪正坐在走廊对面门开着的地方。安迪和我一样沮丧和疯狂。而且他有辆车。
"Andy," I said, "want drive to Princeton and beat up some Princeton kid?"
“安迪，”我说，“想开车去普林斯顿揍一个普林斯顿的孩子吗？”
"Yup," he answered, instantaneously and with surprisingly little emotion in his voice. He didn't even look surprised. It was as if he'd been waiting all night for somebody to walk by and offer a midnight beating of a Princeton student.
“好，”他回答，即刻之间，而且声音里有着令人惊讶的平淡情绪。他甚至没有表现出惊讶。就好像他整晚都在等待有人走过，并提议在午夜揍一个普林斯顿的学生。
We called our other friend, Jeff, who came running over. The three of us dressed in black from head to toe. Black puffy jackets, black pants, black wool hats. We jumped in Andy's car. And we were off.
我们给我们的另一个朋友杰夫打了电话，他跑了过来。我们三个从头到脚都穿着黑色。黑色羽绒服，黑色裤子，黑色羊毛帽。我们跳进安迪的车。然后我们出发了。
"Whoa," I said, when we pulled up at Princeton's gates.
“哇，”当我把车停在普林斯顿的大门口时，我说。
"Yeah," Andy said. "It's beautiful."
“是的，”安迪说。“真漂亮。”
Princeton was the complete opposite of Rutgers.
普林斯顿与罗格斯完全相反。
"It's so clean," Jeff said. We were shocked that a school could be so grime-free. Princeton was clearly not the type of place where you got in without writing an essay.
“太干净了，”杰夫说。我们震惊于一个学校竟然可以如此没有灰尘。普林斯顿显然不是那种你不写文章就进得来的地方。
"We probably shouldn't have dressed in all black," Andy said.
“我们可能不应该穿全黑的，”安迪说。
He was right. Rocking wannabe paramilitary gear was not the best choice if we wanted to go unnoticed. Then we realized Amir's dorm was at the opposite end of campus. We sprinted, scared of being swept up like the state school trash we were.
他是对的。如果我们想不被注意，摇滚风格的准军事装备不是最好的选择。然后我们意识到阿米尔的宿舍在校园的另一头。我们冲刺，害怕像我们这样的州立大学垃圾一样被清理掉。
Luckily for us, it was as if the Princeton-ites couldn't even see us. No one blinked. We had the same effect on them as Columbus's ships did on the Indians. None. They couldn't even fathom that we existed in their reality. We made our way to the dorm and found we needed a magnetic swipe card to enter.
幸运的是，对于我们来说，就好像普林斯顿人甚至看不到我们一样。没有人眨眼。我们对他们的影响和哥伦布的船对印第安人的影响一样。什么都没有。他们甚至无法理解我们在他们的现实中存在。我们走向宿舍，发现我们需要一张磁性刷卡卡才能进入。
That surprised us. At Rutgers, anybody could just walk into any dorm at any time. We responded in the only way we could think of. We tried to kick the door down. It wouldn't give. Luckily for us, though, a young gentleman in a pair of khakis and loafers saw us in our frustration and walked up to us.
那让我们感到惊讶。在罗格斯，任何人都可以随时走进任何宿舍。我们以唯一能想到的方式做出了回应。我们试着踹门。它没有动。幸运的是，一位穿着卡其裤和乐福鞋的年轻绅士看到了我们的挫败感，向我们走了过来。
"Need to get inside?" he asked, smiling.
“需要进去吗？”他微笑着问道。
He looked like an average turn of the 21st century preppy type, but his tone of voice was like Potsie or Dennis the Menace, something from a more innocent time. Clearly this Princeton student hadn't been crushed by the harsh realities of life like we had. He swiped us right in.
他看起来像个21世纪初典型的预科生类型，但他的语调就像波西（Potsie）或丹尼斯（Dennis the Menace），来自一个更纯真的时代。显然这个普林斯顿学生并没有像我们一样被严酷的生活现实所压垮。他刷卡让我们进了去。
When we had left for Princeton, we planned on scaring Amir good. We didn't really think we were going to do any serious damage to him. But what we saw in the lobby of that immaculate, pristinely maintained dorm, changed a lot of things for us that night and, sadly, a lot of things for Amir.
当我们离开前往普林斯顿的时候，我们计划好好吓吓阿米尔。我们并没有真的认为我们会对他造成什么严重的伤害。但在那间干净、保存得一丝不苟的宿舍大厅里所看到的，在那天晚上改变了我们很多东西，而且，悲哀的是，对阿米尔也改变了很多东西。
Gathered in the middle of the dorm were a group of about 15 kids. Every single one of them was wearing sweaters or turtlenecks or both. They were standing around the dorm's grand piano. Grand piano. And they were singing Christmas carols. To drive from the banks of the muddy Raritan, from the 400-person classes, from the bug-infested living areas, from the knowledge that every day for the next four years was going to be a lackluster one to this, to Christmas carols, to the blind, unbothered, let's get together and belt out a good "Silent Night" world of Princeton pushed a button inside all three of us.
聚集在宿舍中间的是大约15个孩子。每个人都穿着毛衣或高领毛衣，或者两者兼有。他们站在宿舍的大钢琴周围。大钢琴。而且他们在唱圣诞颂歌。从泥泞的拉里坦河边，从400人的课程，从虫满为患的居住区，从未来四年每一天都将是乏味一天的知识，来到这里，来到圣诞颂歌，来到普林斯顿那个盲目、不被打扰、“让我们聚在一起大声唱一首好‘平安夜’”的世界，在我们要么三个人中按下一个按钮。
Andy, Jeff, and I all froze, our seething resentment mixing with our collective self-loathing into a dangerously combustible mixture. This wasn't just cheesy. This wasn't just white bread in a way that would never survive at Rutgers. This was a call to war.
安迪、杰夫和我全都僵住了，我们沸腾的怨恨与我们集体自我厌恶混合在一起，变成了一种危险的易燃混合物。这不仅仅是俗气。这不仅仅是那种永远不会在罗格斯生存下来的白面包风格。这是一场战争号角。
We were three kids who existed in a place where we found it hard to feel good about anything. We were three kids who woke up every day a little ticked off about how things were going. Most of all, we were three kids who spent so much time uncertain and angry, that we were scared about whether we were going to turn out OK. And there's no way you sit around singing Christmas carols unless you feel fine about the world. You have to be happy to sing a carol.
我们三个孩子身处一个我们发现很难对任何事情感到良好的地方。我们三个孩子每天醒来时都对事情的发展有点生气。最重要的是，我们三个孩子花费了如此多的时间感到不确定和愤怒，以至于我们害怕自己未来是否会好起来。如果不对自己在这个世界上感到好，你就根本不可能坐在那里唱圣诞颂歌。你必须快乐才能唱颂歌。
I mean, sure. We were spoiled college kids, too. But this? This was taking things to an entirely different level. This was a fantasy world where there were very few problems. And inexplicably, it was sitting right in the middle of our state. Suddenly, without saying a word, all three of us knew. We were going to do our damnedest to destroy this.
我的意思是，当然。我们也是被宠坏的大学生。但这个？这是把事情提升到一个完全不同的水平。这是一个幻想世界，在那里几乎没有什么问题。而且令人费解的是，它就坐在我们州的中间。突然间，没说一句话，我们三个人都知道了。我们要竭尽全力去摧毁这个。
We made our way towards Rob and Amir's floor, heading up the stairwell where we were again thwarted by the presence of a heavy door sealed shut with a magnetic lock. We banged on the door. And as each second ticked by, I realized what a bad idea it was to have come here.
我们朝罗伯和阿米尔的楼层走去，前往楼梯间，在那里我们再次因为一扇被磁锁密封的沉重门的存在而受挫。我们砰砰砰地敲门。随着每一秒的流逝，我意识到来到这里是一个多么糟糕的主意。
This is a bad idea, I thought to myself, that I am about to do. I mean, we were definitely going overboard. We were definitely worked up. And it really wasn't fair to direct it all at one unsuspecting kid. Just as we were coming to our senses, someone opened the door.
这是一个糟糕的主意，我心里想，我正要做的这件事。我的意思是，我们绝对是做得太过火了。我们绝对是受到了刺激。而且把这一切直接对准一个毫无防备的孩子确实是不公平的。就在我们要恢复理智的时候，有人开了门。
The kid was pudgy. His large eyes blinked behind his glasses.
那个孩子胖乎乎的。他大大的眼睛在眼镜后闪烁。
"Can I help you with something?" he asked.
“我能帮你们什么吗？”他问。
"We're friends of Rob's," I mumbled, rocking back and forth on my feet.
“我们是罗伯的朋友，”我嘟囔着，在我的脚上摇来摇去。
He looked back at me, confused.
他困惑地看着我。
"From Rutgers. We called him. He told us we should wait for him until he gets back."
“来自罗格斯。我们给他打了电话。他告诉我们应该等他直到他回来。”
He eyed me up and down. "Well, you can wait with me, I guess," he said, obviously bothered that he'd have to babysit us.
他从上到下打量我。“嗯，你们可以和我一起等，我想，”他说，显然对他不得不照看我们感到很困扰。
He motioned for us to follow him down the hallway. And then, over his shoulder, he signed his own death warrant with three innocuous words.
他示意我们跟着他走过走廊。然后，在他肩膀后面，他用三个无伤大雅的词签下了他自己的死刑判决书。
"My name's Amir."
“我的名字是阿米尔。”
To Amir, Framsky was just a made-up name on the computer screen of some dude he lived down the hall from. He didn't know Framsky went to Rutgers. He didn't know how unhappy Framsky was with the way things were going for him. He was not aware of Framsky's habit of overreacting to small things, of making them out to be symbolic of how his entire life was going. Most importantly, he had no idea Framsky was the skinny weirdo dressed in black staring furiously at the back of his head right at that moment.
对阿米尔来说，Framsky只是他同楼住的一个家伙电脑屏幕上的一个假名字。他不知道Framsky去了罗格斯。他不知道Framsky对事情的发展有多不快乐。他并不知道Framsky对小事过度反应的习惯，把它们当作象征他整个生活状况的习惯。最重要的是，他不知道Framsky就是此时此刻正愤怒地盯着他后脑勺的那个穿着黑色的瘦骨嶙峋的怪胎。
Amir almost seemed tragic to me then. Completely oblivious to the level of fear to which he was going to be introduced that night. I started to feel bad. It was like standing on a hill watching an unsuspecting car about to get blindsided by a speeding truck. With those feelings rising, I knew that if I was going to bail, if I was going to forgive him and walk away, it would have to happen now. I followed him into his dorm. Without turning around, he said, there's some people drinking down the hall. I guess you can come.
阿米尔当时在我看来简直是悲剧。完全没意识到那天晚上他将被介绍到的恐惧程度。我开始感到难过。就像站在山上看着一辆毫无防备的汽车即将被一辆超速行驶的卡车侧面撞击。随着这些感觉上升，我知道如果我要保释，如果我要原谅他并走开，它必须现在发生。我跟着他进了他的宿舍。他没回头说，有些人正在走廊那边喝酒。我想你们可以过来。
When we got to the room in question, there were about 10 kids spread out with their backs to us, all laughing and drinking. Amir announced us.
当我们到达那个房间时，大约有10个孩子背对着我们散开，都在大笑和喝酒。阿米尔宣布了我们的到来。
"Guys, these are Rob's friends from Rutgers."
“伙计们，这是罗伯来自罗格斯的朋友。”
Without even turning around to look at us, one of the girls said, "Oh, I thought something smelled funny in here all of a sudden."
那个女孩甚至没回头看我们，就说：“哦，我以为这里突然间闻起来有什么奇怪的味道。”
She said it quickly. So quickly that it almost seemed planned. Even more quickly than Andy had answered, yeah, he wanted to beat up a Princeton kid. But while I had admired that kind of quickness in Andy, I was aghast when I encountered it in that dorm room.
她说得很快。那么快，它似乎几乎是计划好的。甚至比安迪回答想揍一个普林斯顿学生时还要快。但在我钦佩安迪的那种快的时候，我在那个宿舍房间遇到它时感到震惊。
Who behaves that way? Were they sitting around all night waiting for some poor Rutgers kid to walk through the door just so they could get that killer dig out? These damn smart kids just knew how to think fast and articulate their thoughts. Before the insult, the entire night could have taken a turn right there. We could have sat and drank with those kids all night, burying our stereotypes of each other and uniting in the common bonding of being young and drunk. Instead, we were insulted the second we walked into the room.
谁会那样做？他们是不是整晚都坐在那里等着某个可怜的罗格斯孩子走进来，好让他们能那样说出致命的挖苦话？这些该死的聪明孩子就是知道如何快速思考并清晰表达他们的想法。在侮辱之前，整个晚上本来可以在那里转机。我们本来可以和那些孩子坐在一起喝一整晚，埋葬我们对彼此的刻板印象，并团结在年轻和醉酒的共同纽带中。相反，我们一走进房间就被侮辱了。
At this point, it wasn't just me who was angry. Andy and Jeff were mad as well. They had entered that night as my backup on a silly adventure. Now, they had witnessed college kids singing Christmas carols around their grand piano on a Friday night and had been insulted outright by a very smart, likely very rich, girl.
在这一点上，不仅我生气了。安迪和杰夫也感到愤怒。他们那天晚上作为我愚蠢冒险的后盾进来。现在，他们目睹了大学孩子在周五晚上绕着大钢琴唱圣诞颂歌，并被一个非常聪明、可能非常有钱的女孩直言不讳地侮辱。
Still, my feelings towards Amir were becoming confused. I was angry about what he had done to me. But in a way, I also pitied him. He had initially represented big bad Princeton in our minds. But I knew it wasn't right to take it all out on one guy. At the end of the day, I knew nothing about him. For all I know, he could have been the me of Princeton, the token sad kid.
不过，我对阿米尔的感情开始变得困惑。我对他在我身上所做的事情感到生气。但在某种程度上，我也同情他。他最初在我们的脑海中代表了邪恶的普林斯顿。但我知道把这一切发泄在一个人身上是不对的。归根结底，我对他一无所知。据我所知，他可能就是普林斯顿的那个我，那个代表性的悲伤孩子。
Amir took us back into the hallway. We went down to the other end of the hall and followed him into his room. It was huge. At least three times the size of the space I shared with the Russian bear.
阿米尔把我们带回了走廊。我们走到走廊的另一头，跟着他进了他的房间。它很大。至少是我与俄罗斯熊共享的空间的三倍大。
"Why don't you guys have a seat on the floor?" he said. I watched as he sat in an expensive-looking leather office chair.
“你们为什么不坐在地板上？”他说。我看着他坐在一把昂贵的皮革办公椅上。
There were about six open chairs in his room, not to mention a small couch. But we had been invited to sit on the floor. I now knew everything I needed to know about Amir. He was nothing like me. He was the type of person who thinks it's OK to tell a stranger to sit on the floor.
他的房间里大约有六把空椅子，更不用说一张小沙发了。但我们被邀请坐在地板上。我当时就知道所有我需要知道关于阿米尔的事情了。他和我一点都不像。他属于那种认为告诉陌生人坐在地板上是可以的人。
"Actually, Amir," I said, "I'm going to sit wherever I want."
“其实，阿米尔，”我说，“我想坐在哪就坐在哪。”
His head dropped. He slowly turned around. He suddenly had the body language of someone who realized he was in some pretty deep [BLEEP], the type of deep [BLEEP] where you invite a stranger over, disrespect them before your peers, ridicule them in private, and then realize you know nothing about him.
他的头低了下去。他缓慢地转过身。他突然有了某种肢体语言，仿佛意识到他陷入了非常深的[哔——]，那种你邀请陌生人过来，在你的同辈面前不尊重他们，私下里嘲笑他们，然后意识到你对他一无所知的深[哔——]。
"I'm sorry," he squinted at me. "I never got your name."
“对不起，”他眯着眼看着我。“我从来没问过你的名字。”
I paused and locked eyes with him. I took a deep breath.
我停顿了一下，盯着他的眼睛看。我深吸了一口气。
"My name? My name's Framsky."
“我的名字？我叫Framsky。”
All color drained from his pudgy face. And everything about him suddenly screamed, I want to be back in Toronto right now. He tried to regain his composure.
他胖乎乎的脸上所有的颜色都褪去了。关于他的一切突然间都在尖叫：我现在想回到多伦多。他试着恢复镇定。
"And your friends?" he asked. "What are their names?"
“还有你的朋友们？”他问。“他们叫什么名字？”
He sounded like he thought this was a game. But I wasn't playing a game. I was lonely. I was socially depraved. I was depressed and scared about my life. I snapped.
他听起来像是认为这是一场游戏。但我不是在玩游戏。我很孤独。我在社交上很堕落。我很沮丧并对我的生活感到害怕。我崩溃了。
"Their name is Framsky, too, mother[BLEEP]." I leaned in close to him. "Don't you ever [BLEEP] with me again."
“他们也叫Framsky，你这混蛋。”我靠近他。“别再招惹我了。”
I don't even remember what I said next. All I know is I was lashing out. And it was working. He was terrified.
我甚至不记得接下来我说了什么。我只知道我当时在痛斥。而且它正在起作用。他被吓坏了。
"You have to go," Amir said. "You have to go right now."
“你们得走，”阿米尔说。“你们现在得走。”
I ignored him. "Don't you ever [BLEEP] with me. You have no idea what it's like out there. You have no idea who I am."
我忽略了他。“别再招惹我。你不知道外面是什么样子。你不知道我是谁。”
From the look in his eyes, I knew he was realizing that I was right. He didn't have any idea what it was like out there. He had as much of an idea of what my New Jersey was as I did his.
从他的眼神中，我知道他意识到我是对的。他根本不知道外面是什么样子。他和我了解他的新泽西一样了解我的新泽西。
And that's when I spread out my arms, leaned in as close as I could get to his face, and said the toughest thing I've ever said in my life.
就在那时，我张开双臂，尽可能地靠近他的脸，说了我一生中说过的最强硬的话。
"I am in your house, Amir." I grinned. "I'm in your [BLEEP] house, and there's nothing you can do about it."
“我在你的房子里，阿米尔。”我笑了。“我在你的[哔——]房子里，你对此无能为力。”
He looked at me and the first tear trickled down his cheek. I couldn't believe it. Only at a place like Princeton could a guy who looks like me be the bully instead of the bullied.
他看着我，第一滴眼泪顺着他的脸颊流了下来。我简直不敢相信。只有在像普林斯顿这样的地方，一个看起来像我的人才会是欺凌者而不是被欺凌者。
"You have to go right now," he said, taking a step towards me.
“你们现在得走，”他说，向我迈出了一步。
"I am in your house," I repeated.
“我在你的房子里，”我重复道。
"Go, leave," he said, trying desperately to control his fear. He took one more step, and he pushed me.
“走，离开，”他说，拼命试着控制他的恐惧。他迈出了又一步，他推了我。
That was a mistake. I spun around.
那是一个错误。我转过身来。
"Framsky," I said, making eye contact with Jeff. "Lock the door."
“Framsky，”我说，与杰夫有眼神交流。“锁门。”
"We need to leave," Jeff answered. I looked at him. He was no longer angry. He was scared. Of me.
“我们得离开，”杰夫回答。我看着他。他不再生气了。他很害怕。害怕我。
Back at Rutgers, Andy and Jeff hung out in my room for the rest of the night. We assumed the police were going to arrive at any moment and that our gathering in one place was a polite way to make their job easier. I don't know what I was more scared of, my impending arrest or the behavior I'd seen in myself that night. I'd always been an angry kid, but, for the first time, I'd seen that anger lash outwards. I had almost brutalized a stranger. Worst of all, I wasn't sure which I felt worse about, almost doing it or not doing it.
回到罗格斯，安迪和杰夫在我的房间里待了剩下的晚上。我们假设警察随时都会到达，而我们聚在一个地方是一种使他们工作更容易的礼貌方式。我不知道我更害怕什么，我即将到来的逮捕还是那天晚上我在自己身上看到的行为。我一直是个愤怒的孩子，但，第一次，我看到那种愤怒向外迸发。我几乎残暴对待了一个陌生人。最糟糕的是，我不确定我对差点做这件事还是没做这件事感到更糟糕。
To our amazement, the police never called. I'd like to say that seeing this side of myself changed me. But over the next four years, I had another half dozen incidents like it, including three other guys who, in my head, became the enemy of everything I stood for and the night I initiated a high speed chase with a New Jersey state trooper. But finally, I got myself together. I just looked up Amir on Facebook and realized things worked out for us exactly the way they are supposed to for a kid from Rutgers and a guy from Princeton.
令我们惊讶的是，警察从未打来电话。我想说看到我的这一面改变了我。但在接下来的四年里，我又经历了六次类似的事件，包括其他三个在我脑海中成为了我所代表的一切的敌人的人，以及我引发了一场与新泽西州警车的高速追逐的夜晚。但最终，我让自己振作起来了。我刚在Facebook上查了阿米尔，并意识到事情按照罗格斯的孩子和普林斯顿的家伙应该有的方式为我们解决了。
He's a banker in Europe. And if the girl in his profile photo is his girlfriend, he has a hot girlfriend. I live in an apartment with a roommate in Queens, arguably the fourth coolest borough in New York City. And I'm still telling the story, about the 12-hour window when I was tough back in 1998.
他是欧洲的一名银行家。如果他个人资料照片中的女孩是他女朋友，他有一个性感的女朋友。我住在皇后区与一位室友的公寓里，可以说是纽约第四酷的区。我仍然在讲那个故事，关于1998年我变硬的那12个小时窗口。
Chris Gethard. That story is the title story of his new book, A Bad Idea I'm About To Do , which comes out in just a couple weeks, in January.
克里斯·格哈德。那个故事是他新书的标题故事，《我即将要做的一件坏事》，这本书还有几周就要出版了，在1月份。
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Miki Meek. Scouting help from Elna Baker. Music help from Damien Graef from Rob Geddis.
嗯，我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。制作协助来自米基·米克（Miki Meek）。侦察协助来自埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can listen to any of our shows for absolutely free and find links to our mobile apps for Android, iPhone, and iPad-- the iPhone and iPad apps, by the way, you can actually gift to a friend by clicking the little down arrow next to the app in the iTunes store. The web address, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，在那里你可以完全免费地收听我们的任何节目，并找到我们Android、iPhone和iPad移动应用程序的链接——顺便说一下，iPhone和iPad应用程序，你可以通过点击iTunes商店中应用程序旁边的小向下箭头将其赠送给朋友。网址，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He has such weird nicknames for our WBEZ colleague, Peter Sagal--
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ的管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。他给我们WBEZ的同事彼得·萨加尔（Peter Sagal）起了一些很奇怪的绰号——
The potato, the midget, Napoleon, also, because of his height. Psychopath, schizophrenic.
土豆、侏儒、拿破仑，也是因为他的身高。精神病患者、精神分裂症患者。
I don't know what he's talking about. I like Peter. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我不知道他在说什么。我喜欢彼得。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。